Speaker 1: Hey, everybody. Welcome to The
David Pakman Show. I'm producer Pat Forde,
filling in for David today. David is on vacation
for much of this week. He will be back on Friday.
A number of Republicans are calling for the
arrest of Joe Biden and also Hunter Biden
and any other Democrats that they can possibly
trumped up charges against as a way to retaliate
against Donald Trump getting indicted and
then arrested last week in New York. Now,
what issues do they want to arrest Biden
and these other Democrats over? That's not
as important. They just want to do this because
they see it as a way to get vindication. Right.
Because Donald Trump, for once in his entire life,
is finally being held accountable to some degree,
to some small degree after his years and years
of criminality. I spoke about this matter on last
week's Friday bonus show, the award winning world
famous bonus show, I might add. But there have
since been more Republicans adding to this chorus
of right wing calls to do something like this to
to levy charges against Joe Biden and these other
Democrats. First and foremost, we're hearing from
Congressman James Comer, who chairs the House
Oversight Committee. He went on Fox and Friends
late last week to comment on how there are these
district attorneys in places like Kentucky and
Tennessee who are trying to come up with
some way to charge the Bidens, even though
they don't know what issue they're going to
do it over. Let's take a look at this clip.
Speaker 2: And I had two calls yesterday, one
from a county attorney in Kentucky and one from
a county attorney in Tennessee. They were
Republican, obviously, that both states are
heavily Republican. They want to know if there are
ways they can go after the Bidens now. And they've
opened up a can of worms. They've set precedents
now that we can't go back on. And now we're going
to see a judicial system that's already bogged
down with doing what they're supposed to do,
and that's going after real criminals,
people that are committing real crimes.
Speaker 1: Now, what jurisdiction would these days
have to indict Biden? There, of course, isn't any
because the crime would have had to take place in
one of those two states. Remember Donald Trump's
hush money payment that took place in New York
City? And where are the charges coming from about
this? You guessed it, New York City. The issues
that Republicans talk about potentially indicting
Biden on have to do with his supposed corruption,
even though they really can't articulate it all
that well. But they'll mention Ukraine or China
or some other foreign country. Sometimes they'll
talk about the classified documents scandal that
implicated Joe Biden, even though Donald Trump
is way more guilty on that topic. So if you're
going to go after Biden on this, it stands to
reason you'd also have to go after Donald Trump.
If you do go after Biden on any of these topics,
it would probably need to come from the federal
governments or at least involve the states in
question like the supposed crime that took
place would have had to have taken place in
one of these states. But the fact is that this
has nothing to do with, you know, trying to stay
consistent or trying to uphold the rule of law or
trying to, you know, make sure that this is done
in a proper way. It really is just about getting
vindication. We're also now hearing from whiney,
hysterical right wing talk show host Mark Levin
about this topic. He's also trying to get someone,
anyone to charge Joe Biden and the Democrats for
what? Again, not important, but he just knows that
it has to be done. Here's Mark Levin.
Speaker 3: And once again,
from multiple times the show's heard all over the
country. It's heard all over the world, actually.
I'm asking Republican prosecutors out there
to take a very good look at your own statutes,
local, state and even federal, but
particularly the state prosecutors,
the DA's, the state prosecutors and so forth.
See if there's anything there that you can use
to charge Biden or any senior Democrat official.
I mean, if you're not 100% certain, you're
80% certain that it'll fly, then do it.
So the only way this will stop. Do it. Because
otherwise this will continue. You'd be doing it
for your country. You'd be doing it in the name
of the law. It is a legitimate reply in response.
It's the only way to at least begin the
process of clawing us back from the abyss
because we're already falling into the abyss.
Speaker 1: In addition to the days in Tennessee
and Kentucky that Conor mentioned and Mark Levin
talking about how we got to charge Biden, we're
also hearing from Tom Fitton, who is the president
of the conservative legal group Judicial Watch. He
said, quote, All bets are off. You can expect
grand jury indictments of leftist politicians
like Biden, former House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer as surely as
night follows day. Mike Davis, a former chief
counsel for nominations on the Senate Judiciary
Committee and president of the Article three
project, said that, quote, If New York can turn
a routine settlement of a business dispute seven
years ago into a felony, I think our Republican
AGs and D.A. should get creative. Get creative is
what he says. Like he seems to admit there that
there's no actual reason to charge the Bidens. It
would be right to do so. But he wants them to get
creative. He went on to say that two wrongs don't
make a right, but it does make it even. And that's
what this is about, getting even. So he's out now
saying, yeah, we're we're just going to make it
up. We're just going to come up with whatever
reason we can charge the Bidens on hearing from
these Republicans. You would think that Donald
Trump just didn't get a pass like he did over
and over again throughout the entire course of
his political career. He did get a pass and now
he's finally to the smallest degree, being held
accountable for just one of these alleged crimes.
This is the hush money payment, of course, the
incident that took place back in 2016. His then
fixer, Michael Cohen, who has since been a guest
on this program, went to prison over this. Donald
Trump was a sitting president at the time, and
he was protected by this idea that there's this
long standing precedent that you can't charge a
sitting president. It hasn't actually been tested
before. But that's long been the tradition here
in this country. But that wasn't the only issue
that you could have possibly gone after Trump
on. Of course, there was the Russia scandal
where Robert Mueller concluded his report that
Donald Trump should be charged for obstruction of
justice. But since it was believed you couldn't
indict a sitting president, he was saying that
it's actually Congress's responsibility to hold
him accountable, accountable Congress should
impeach Donald Trump. And of course, they ended
up not doing that. Then there was the scandal
in Ukraine, which would have been criminal if done
by anyone else who was not a sitting president,
you know, withholding congressionally approved
aid from a country, saying that he's not going
to give that to him unless they dig up dirt on
his political opponent. Then there's, of course,
the fraudulent business practices that the Trump
organization committed where he would inflate the
value of his assets when it was time to take out
a loan and he would deflate them when it was time
to pay taxes. They chose not to go after Trump
personally on this matter just to hold the company
accountable. There's obviously the phone call in
Georgia where he pressured Brad Raffensperger to
find him, 11,280 votes that didn't exist when
it was clear that he had lost the election.
Hopefully, there will be some accountability on
that. Hopefully, we eventually get some charges
out of Georgia, but thus far, it hasn't happened.
There's the January 6th insurrection where he sent
his supporters to the Capitol to commit a coup,
and then he didn't try to stop them. Once the
coup is actually unfolding, there's a classified
document scandal, which I alluded to before, where
he took sensitive information to Mar a Lago and
then lied about giving the documents back when he
actually didn't got to the point where the FBI had
to actually conduct a search on his home and seize
the documents to get them back to the National
Archives. So all of these things and more all of
these things are indictable infractions. He's only
so far being held accountable for one of them,
just one of them. And it's probably the least
serious of all of them. And for whatever reason,
Republicans feel as though this is grounds
to go after Democrats on and, you know,
make this a tit for tat sort of thing. So
Trump has gotten away with so much. What
would it take for Republicans to accept that
he was actually worthy of prosecution without
turning this into a political game? Like, would
he actually have to shoot someone on Fifth Avenue,
even if that happened? Even if he did shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue, I think they would
still bring the conversation back to Hunter
Biden and the laptop from hell. But that's
the latest Republicans trying to make up charges
against Joe Biden and the other Democrats that
they want to make their new political targets. I
hope that the American public sees through this.
I hope that if Biden actually is indicted for some
reason, then that the American public will be able
to understand that it's Republicans just trying
to play dirty political games. And Biden isn't
actually worthy of being charged for anything.
But that's what Republicans are doing right now.